incrédulité incompréhension sur la scène
internationale n'ont pas empêché le
sénat polonais de voter à 57 voix contre
23 une loi qui fera l'histoire
dorénavant quiconque osera mentionné que
les polonais ont qui était complice de
l'extermination des juifs pendant la
seconde guerre mondiale sera passible de
trois ans de prison
les polonais non juifs polonais
chrétiens ont participé dans la
persécution de divers manière de leurs
concitoyens juifs
auteur de nombreux livres cet historien
de l'université princeton a été un des
premiers à faire la lumière sur les
massacres des juifs non pas par les
allemands mais par des polonais
notamment ici dans ce village de l'est
de la pologne où 400 ont été brûlés vifs
par leurs concitoyens
c'est une pacification de l'histoire
sans connaître leur propre histoire les
polonais ne pourront pas être une
société s'est occupée par l'allemagne la
pologne abrité pendant la guerre
pratiquement tous les camps de
concentration et d'extermination nazis
90% des 3 million trois cent mille juifs
polonais y ont trouvé la mort
le rôle des polonais dans
l'extermination des juifs a longtemps
été tabou
cet historien de l'université d'ottawa
en a fait son principal champ de
recherche ce qui sort ressort très
clairement de mes recherches
les différentes couches sociales
différents groupes parfois aussi dirigé
par l'autorité locale se sont insérés
dans le système allemand d'extermination
le président qui doit maintenant apposé
sa signature pour que la loi entre en
vigueur a été clair ni l'état polonais
ni la nation polonaise n'ont participé
d'aucune manière a le low cost at il dit
c'est en israël où vit la plus grande
communauté de survivants que le choc a
été le plus grand la knesset a voté pour
une loi criminalisant la négation de la
complicité dans les crimes nazis
les spis certains certes que l'adoption
de cette loi au même bataille autour de
cette loi va faire grimper la popularité
du parti nationaliste au pouvoir auprès
de l'opinion publique en pole à
plusieurs aujourd'hui se demande si tel
n'était pas le principal but de cette
loi au risque de ternir encore plus
l'image de la pologne
déjà mise à mal par un déficit
démocratique et par la prolifération
d'une extrême droite nationaliste et
xénophobe
ici avec sandra chaska radio canada
montréal